now so far we have understood
this idea of angular displacement
angular velocity etc
distinguishing it from linear velocity
what's actually happening in terms of
distance over time
and then we can think about revolutions
um rate frequency
right by the way i mentioned to you
before that um
a way of working out the period of
motion is to say
2 pi on omega 2 pi omega now remember
with
all your trig functions right period is
the sort of converse of frequency right
like how
how frequently does this go around two
pi out omega
will give you the period because
frequency is the opposite idea if you
want frequency all you need is omega
on two pi right omega on two pi that'll
get you back
to um you know how many revolutions per
second which i think will be
uh four thirds of a revolution per
second in this particular example
okay so sometimes you'll be asked for
this sometimes you'll be asked for that
frequency
and you of course can just logic it out
just think about what's going on like
80 revolutions per minute i can work
that out or you can just use these
formulas if you're happy with it
okay but but
with our current understanding that's
pretty much it
that's all you can ask um this is tricky
but it's not extension two
this is like this is sort of extension
one level of looking at
um uniform circular motion okay if you
want to know more if you want to be able
to pose more interesting questions
and ask more challenging um uh solve
more challenging problems rather
you're gonna have to willing to dig
deeper right so the question then
becomes
what do i want to know what's worth
knowing about a situation like this
and how do i get to that knowledge how
do i get to that now we're in mechanics
right
mechanics what distinguished mechanics
from extension one motion what were the
new there were two big ideas that sort
of came together yeah
yeah forces which of course go along
with max
right if you think about mass and then
you think about all these things you put
them together you get forces okay
so i'm going to pose the question here
are very simple things i can ask about
this
but if i want to know about the forces
that are going around for instance
this is an actual question why is it
that as you went round and round around
so many of you fell apart that's an
actual question that we can answer
right your hands down we're going to be
able to answer that question but we can
only answer it
in terms of forces okay so if forces are
what i want to know
force is what i want to know and the
next question is well how do i get to
that
how do i get to an expression for the
forces that are going on here
i want you to remember this is uniform
circular motion okay
so therefore every position on the
circle
can be described in terms of your
angular
displacement right because you're on a
circle what are the coordinates of a
point
given an angle theta and like a radius r
okay this is just our familiar
parametric representation
of the coordinates of a circle right so
what i've got there
is an expression wrong color is an
expression for
the horizontal displacement and
an expression for the vertical
displacement okay so that's really good
i can use these i can combine them
together to work out what forces is
going on here
right so for instance like where i'm
headed is
you can see um i'm not going to draw an
ink actually no i could i couldn't
manage
if i draw in the um linear
velocity over here headed off in that
direction okay
if you look at this you can see a
component of this thing back to like
projectile motion i think back to
projectile version
a component of this is going in the
vertical direction
right and another component is going in
the horizontal direction
yes does that make sense
now maybe you see maybe you're thinking
wait a second why are my lines going off
in those directions i'll let you have a
think for a moment as to why
they have to be headed this way and not
that way you just have to think about it
okay i'll resolve the answer for you a
bit later if it's not clicking for you
okay but i just want to give these guys
names i'm going to call this
a force over here and a force over here
named after the directions they're going
in
okay so in order to get to what these
guys are
i need to rip out the part of this
tangential velocity
that's going to go in this direction and
the path is going to go in that
direction that's how i'm gonna have to
get this out
and the way i'm gonna get to those is
using each of these expressions right
i'm gonna think about just like in
projectile motion i have to do all the x
stuff then i have to do all the y stuff
it ends up being somewhat repetitive but
i have to do it first so i can combine
them at the
end okay so let's begin
if i have x equals r cos theta
right i want to know how is this
changing with respect to time this is
displacement
isn't so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to differentiate this expression
once and that's going to get me to if
you differentiate displace it with
respect to time you get to velocity
right so velocity
is what i'm trying to find okay well
it's what i'm going to find and then
i'll keep going down eventually i'll get
some forces okay
so here i'm going to say well that's dx
on
dt that's how to differentiate that
right but i have a
teeny problem tiny problem this is not
an expression it's not a function of
time
right so i can't differentiate with
respect to time at least not usefully
right it's a function of theta so i must
differentiate it with respect to
theta right so if i can only
differentiate this with respect to
theta right but i actually want things
in terms of time
i'm going to have to use chain rule here
to be able to change the variables in
terms of right what am i going to have
to multiply
the theta on dt you see why each of the
bad data that's okay um i've got the d
thetas there they have to cancel with
each other
but the reason i had in the first place
is this is an expression in terms of
theta
dt is there because that's what i want
this to be in terms of so you can see
that that's fine
okay uh dx on d theta you can tell me
what that is in this case
okay we nailed it this time okay that
cos theta tends to a negative sine theta
r is just a constant d theta on dt
ah i have a name for this i call this
omega
okay very good so this this
is the velocity in horizontal terms so
i'm just going to call that v of x
okay like i said we have to do this for
both sides let's just quickly uh
go through that process but for the
vertical coordinates so i've got
y equals r sine theta i've got to pull
the same trick again
so if i want to differentiate with
respect to time
in order to do it with a function in
terms of theta i have to use chain rule
right so i'm going to go d y on d theta
and again surprise surprise
d theta under t okay guys derivative
with respect to theta r cos theta and
then again omega appears
okay now i'm just going to pause for a
moment we're still in uniform
circular motion land right uh as you can
imagine
uniform circular motion being so
predictable is a lot easier to deal with
than originally non-uniform circular
motion
what was it that made uniform circular
motion uniform do you remember
the uh angular velocity very good
so omega here i mean i'm currently
considering it
just as a number just as a constant
later on we'll have a
part of your homework we think about
well now what happens if it's actually
changing if omega is changing
if that's not a number but a function
that will complicate this
considerably but i'll let you have a
look at it later
right we differentiated once that goes
to velocity i'm trying to get to forces
right
so i better differentiate again
what's this going to give me
acceleration
okay so if i take this guy
here so i'm going to differentiate the
horizontal
component with respect to time what am i
going to have to do
think about how i did it before i have
to do the same thing again
don't i um this is still a function of
theta like it was before
so i can only differentiate it v of x
with respect to
theta but if i want it to be actually
with respect to time then i'm gonna have
to pull in this d theta on dt business
again
chain rule so that's fine okay all right
negative r sine theta differentiates two
negative r constant yep okay
um i've already got by the way an omega
i should actually include that inside
right because that was also one of the
constants and then i have to multiply by
this guy
because i differentiated again so this
there's an omega again yep
so i can write this guy as minus or
negative r
there are two omegas so omega squared
cos theta yeah
okay are you happy with that so far can
you do it again
for the vertical component